today on first we feast and complex you
pour DJ Paul Kayla will go teach you how
to pimp out your Super Bowl spread going
down Oh
don't bring shitty bean dip to a Super
Bowl party if you got less than seven
layers dude
please keep it cool in the room where
you watching the game so nobody have to
move to get a beer dude provide your own
halftime entertainment like stickers and
DJs playing nothing but three C's much
don't bring so many chips then everybody
fills up on Tostitos and don't have room
for your chicken I do have separate TVs
for people to actually want to watch the
game there's people that won't don't
ever ever double dip don't share your
political conspiracy theories and don't
touch the [ __ ] remote control not do
create crazy-ass best to squeeze money
out of all your guests I got a wreck
that says Russell Wilson would get his
hair cut by white dude in the next
Microsoft good Monday not me then change
me don't push me because I'm close to
the edge do bring something to the party
of your guests and not no dumb edible
arrangements appropriate items I'll read
boom some DJ Paul barbecue sauce all
right so you just people all the do's
and don'ts make sure you don't [ __ ] up
your Super Bowl party man keep the beer
cold keep some DJ power barbecue
products I'm dick
check out all the links below for all my
other recipes and keep it locked right
here the first we feast and complex see
you next time